or so here what you're doing you can
start off at the first number two okay
so let's start right over here at two
and when you subtract okay that means
you're taking away right so when you
subtract that means you're actually
gonna be going backwards okay but when
you work with negative numbers see the
negative three here negative numbers
actually tell you to do the opposite
okay so if you're subtracting normally
we would go backwards one two three
because it's getting smaller but the
negative number tells us to do the
opposite so we're actually going to go
instead of going backwards three we're
going to go forwards three one two three
and you can see we end up at five okay
so we understand about negative numbers
doing the opposite we understand how
subtraction normally takes us backwards
on the number line but I'm going to show
you a shortcut and this will help you as
you do more complicated problems what
you can do is when you see a subtraction
problem think of it as an addition
problem so what we're going to do is
subtraction is really like adding the
opposite so if you change this from
subtraction to addition you want to
change this sign to the opposite if it's
positive you make it negative if it's
negative you make it positive now you
can see we have a simple problem here
it's just two plus three which we
learned a long time ago that's just five
right okay let's go to the next one
negative three minus one okay one way to
think about this is the number line you
could start at negative three
subtraction says we're gonna go to the
left one place and we're at negative
four right easy the other way to do it
is we could say hmm subtraction is like
adding the opposites if I change this I
don't want to change the overall value
of the problem I have to change this to
the opposite so negative three plus
negative one we can talk about the scale
like we talked about in the previous
video about comparing you know positive
and negative numbers if we have a
negative three plus negative one it's
like stacking up three bricks on the
left side plus another brick on the left
side the scale is going to tilt to the
left because it's heavier by 4 bricks
okay there's nothing on the right to
counterbalance it so we have negative
four over here in this example negative
four minus negative
- so what I would do okay if you wanted
to think of the number line we'd start
off over here at negative four okay if
we subtract we would go to the left
right because subtracting is making the
numbers smaller but we're working with a
negative two negative numbers tell us to
do the opposite so instead of going left
- we're gonna go right - and that's
gonna put us at negative two now it gets
a little bit more complicated when you
start having all these negatives in your
problem so what I suggest and recommend
after you have a feel for how positive
and negative numbers work is just take
this little shortcut and make
subtraction like adding the opposite if
you change this sign change this to the
opposite and you've got it so we've got
negative 4 plus 2 think about putting 4
bricks on this side 2 bricks on this
side which way is it going to tilt well
it's going to tilt to the heavier side
right why because it's heavier by 2 okay
2 of these are gonna cancel out with two
of these that would be balanced but it's
actually heavier on that side by 2 and
so you can see you're gonna have
negative 2 it's tilting towards a
negative side ok the last example here
we're subtracting so that's like adding
the opposite we have a negative 700 plus
a negative 100 okay so you spend $700 +
you spend another hundred dollars so far
you've spent $800 so you've decreased
whatever was in your account let's say
by $800 so these are just some simple
and easy and direct ways to work with
positive and negative numbers when
you're subtracting just think about
changing it to adding the opposite and
then you can use that scale analogy that
I was showing you and you'll you'll have
it so I'll see you in the next video